[Music]
[Applause]
he's Dave Roberts Dodger manager
two-time World Series champion and um I
don't know if you know this Dave but you
have a penino Noir The Red Stitch
friends and family it just received do
you know what the rating was from wine
spectator I don't break the news come on
Dan 93
really hey well done Red Stitch thank
you Dan yeah just wanted to let you know
that your Pino Noir got a 93 uh probably
nothing else to talk to you about Dave
so that was it just wanted to give you
an update on your
wine yeah there's nothing going on in
sports or baseball absolutely not well
hey good chatting what role did you play
in signing or helping to sign show heot
Tani so you know it it's it was it's uh
OB viously I think it started obviously
in uh 16 when we courted them as many
people did and I think that you know I
think Dan is like over time and you can
tell shi's very cerebral very thoughtful
in his words very observant and over the
course of the last six years as we've
dug in on him and as we do all players
I'm sure he dug in on me you know with
players and coaches that he was with
with the angels and around the league
and so I think there was a process uh as
far as kind of the shorter term near
term uh you know it was the it was the
meeting that we had and kind of
finalizing some things and talking about
what daytoday life would look like as a
Dodger and and for me um certainly with
my Japanese Heritage my background uh we
have a great connection and uh Mike
Trout and I have a good connection and
Dino eel who was a coach over there so
I'm sure that uh Shi did his due
diligence with me so honestly Dan we hit
it off really well and uh he just kind
of wanted to see how things are going to
be so I feel really good about where
we're at and contining to build that
relationship going forward how much
Japanese do you
speak so not much um I I could say the
uh the easy
scosi um I know a couple words you know
tomadachi I can count to like 20 but I
do need to get better man absolutely can
you count to 700 million
Dave absolutely not what about that uh
iconic historical contract but the thing
about that though Dan which is great is
that this is something that shohi and
Nez brought to the Dodgers and even
Andrew said I wouldn't have had the guts
to present some type of structure like
that to a player but that speaks to what
shohi wanted you know uh for as far as
being competitive uh uh you know
appreciating the CBT uh you know for the
years that we can look out as a Dodger
as far as well pitching's off the table
this year what position is chi going to
be playing do you think on a regular
basis it's uh two initials two letters
DH so uh he's going to DH and um you
know he's taking dry swings now and his
goal is to be ready by opening day and
so uh you know I hope that holds but you
know he's going to be ready when he's
going to be ready and then he's going to
start taking uh some soft toss and
things like that but this guy is so Uber
competitive Dan and that's one thing
that you know the humility there you
know the talents there but I really
didn't appreciate uh you know the the
real drive and I saw that documentary
that he had and how thoughtful he was so
uh he'll be ready at some point as far
as the hitting and then the pitching is
going to be picked up next year you're
planning on him being a two-way player
after this
year absolutely and you know there was
even a little talk with shohi um about
you know come September when he can pick
up a baseball and throw uh would he be
open to uh taking some balls out there
in left field and he said if it works
and my arm feels okay you know I'm open
to it so we'll see um but we got a lot
of time before we get to that point when
did you know you had
him when my son when we were at a life
uh a celebration of life for his uh
roommate's father in college uh showed
me the phone and said we got show so I
think what was great Dan I think I found
out I think you found out minutes before
I found out um I don't do social media
so I think my son told me and Shi as you
can tell Dan wanted to control this
whole narrative which I respect I
appreciate so um I think I found out
when everyone else found out out can you
talk about Tyler
glaso so I I don't know I mean obviously
it's out uh I I don't know if uh
physicals are are final I think it's
going to be hopefully announced later
today um so I'm excited um you know I
mean I think the pieces that they've
talked about are the pieces so it's amaz
amazing uh in sports today how things
get out I don't know how it got out but
uh sort of with respect to to pepio and
Johnny Duca I don't want to go too far
into it but I do think that if if
everything kind of tees are crossed eyes
are dotted physically are passed then it
should kind of go through but uh if it
does play out you know we're really
excited uh to to get a player like that
and also Manny Margo how close were the
Dodgers to getting Otani the first time
around you know I I I don't think we
were uh um I I think that we put our
best foot forward but I think ultimately
he wanted an opportunity to be in the
lineup uh essentially every day uh to
then pitch and I think as I recall we
presented something where you know we
could try to formulate
250 275 played appearances with the with
the uh the uh play Left Field pinch
at times you know
with kind of appreciating his pitching
schedule but you can't compare to 600
player appearances that an American
League team wanted I think he was really
comfortable uh in Anaheim kind of uh the
market the the geography as well what
about uh his relationship with uh
yoshinobu
Yamamoto is do they have an existing
relationship and uh are you using him as
a
recruiter absolutely Al uh we're we're
doing that uh we'd be crazy not to um I
I think that with that uh Team Japan
which as we all saw Dan that that was
pretty special I mean obviously uh they
beat the US and you know um seeing sh
versus trout that that's some that
moment right there in in sports was uh
something I'll always remember as well
many people but uh they were teammates
and so uh I I do know that uh Yoshino
noou uh you know is excited uh being
recruited uh we hosted them and I
thought we did a really good job and had
players there to kind of uh see what
life would look like some some uh what
of normaly you know uh being around our
guys and having lunch and kind of having
one-off conversations with his potential
teammates uh as well as showing Dodger
Stadium things like that so yeah they do
have a good relationship so hopefully
everything lines up and it would be
quite the
offse great to talk to you Dave I know
you're uh short on time and always great
to talk to you congratulations on your
uh your wine uh your penino
Noir so Dan thank you so much man it's
always good chatting with you so I'm
heading out to Madison Club right now so
if you got a free weekend man come out
and join me and let's uh play a little
golf buddy now the the first tea at the
Madison Club they give you a shot of
vodka the iced shot glass and then you
have to throw it and try to hit like a
bell don't
you so it's tequila it is a little ice
class and I have been known to to hit
the Bell and get a shot uh hat that says
shots so uh if I do hit the Bell I'm
going to shoot you a text if you don't
hear from me it's not good well uh great
to talk to you as always and thanks
again
Dave later DP that's Dave Roberts the
Dodger manager me